in the south
a 14-ton bread truck is impaled on rocks
tord and andre were attempting to lift
it clear
until it threatened to crash back down
with toured underneath
you know we have to be carefully because
this is nothing to
kidding
[Music]
we're putting a material under the wheel
so if something happened it
will not go so long down so there is
space for us we always take the save
first
andre brings in a heavy-duty airbag
capable of lifting
30 tons to bolster the trolley jacks
using an electric compressor he has to
inflate it quickly
to stabilize the truck
hello
with everyone clear they try again to
haul out the huge rocks
[Music]
because the airbag holds up the bread
truck it should be a piece of cake to
pull out the last few rocks
[Music]
now we have take some very big stones
away
under the truck so now we are very happy
but this job is only half baked
the bread truck is still stuck tord and
andre
now have to winch it up onto the road
take it out from this place
go for the garage and repair
inching it forward on wooden tracks tord
must not let the truck slip
slinger full swing under my arm
swing full swing
must avoid holding up traffic
[Music]
my plan is always working
and this time too this weekend
today is the best people working
together so now
andrea go to garage and then maybe
monday it's prepared and you can drive a
new trip with
bread in uh
[Music]
you